>> I AM ASHAMED BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT MR. TRUMP IS.
HE IS A RACIST.
HE IS A CON MAN.
AND HE IS A CHEAT.
MR. TRUMP KNEW OF AND DIRECTED
THE TRUMP MOSQUE ON THROUGHOUT
THE
CAMPAIGN AND LIED ABOUT IT.
HE LIED ABOUT IT BECAUSE HE
NEVER EXPECTED TO WIN.
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED OF
WHETHER I KNOW ABOUT DIRECT
EVIDENCE THAT MR. TRUMP OR HIS
CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA.
I DO NOT.
>> Bret: MICHAEL COHEN,
8300 MILES AWAY FROM HANOI,
VIETNAM, AS WE GET READY FOR
THIS SUMMIT HERE TESTIFYING
ABOUT A HOST OF ISSUES, THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN PUTTING OUT A
STATEMENT TODAY SAYING THAT
MICHAEL COHEN IS A FELON, A
CONVICTED PERJURER WHO LIED TO
THE SPECIAL
, CONGRESS AND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THIS IS THE SAME MICHAEL COHEN
WHO HAS ADMITTED TO LYING TO
CONGRESS PREVIOUSLY.
WHY DID THEY BOTHER SWEARING HIM
IN THIS TIME?
CHARLES HURT, OPINION EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
MARIE HARF, AND
"WASHINGTON POST" COLUMNIST MARC
THIESSEN.
>> THIS WAS THE BOMBSHELL THAT
DIDN'T EXPLODE.
A LOT OF STUFF THAT WAS
EMBARRASSING FOR DONALD TRUMP
AND MOST EMBARRASSING WAS HIS
ASSOCIATION WITH MICHAEL COHEN.
REMEMBER, BEFORE THE TESTIMONY
THAT THERE WAS ALL THIS
TESTIMONY THAT MICHAEL COHEN
RECORDED CONVERSATIONS WITH
DONALD TRUMP, KNOWING ABOUT THE
TRUMP TOWER MEETING.
TURNS OUT HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY OF
THAT.
DIDN'T HAVE ANY EVIDENCE OF
ANYTHING THAT WAS IMPEACHABLE.
IN FACT, SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS HE SAID WAS ACTUALLY
EXCULPATORY.
YOU PLAYED THAT CLIP AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEGMENT WHERE
HE SAID THAT DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T
EXPECT TO WIN.
HE SAID ELSEWHERE THAT HE
TREATED THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN AS AN
INFOMERCIAL FOR THE TRUMP BRAND.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, THAT
UNDERMINES THE ARGUMENT THAT THE
PAYOFF FOR STORMY DANIELS WAS A
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATIONS
BECAUSE IT'S ONLY A CRIME IF HE
WAS DOING IT TO ADVANCE HIS
CAMPAIGN.
IF HE WAS DOING IT TO NOT
EMBARRASS HIS WIFE OR -- THAT
SLEAZY, BUT IT'S NOT CRIMINAL.
MICHAEL KAUFMAN PROVIDED
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE THAT
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T COMMIT A
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
>> Bret: DEFINITELY DIDN'T
HAVE INFORMATION ON COLLUSION.
AS TO YOUR POINT TO THE STORMY
DANIELS' PAYMENT AND THE OTHER
PAYMENT THAT HE SAID WERE
RETAINERS, HERE IS THAT EXCHANGE
WITH THE ONE OF THE CONGRESSMAN.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES THUS WROTE A
PERSONAL CHECK FOR THE PAYMENT
OF HUSH MONEY AS PART OF A
CRIMINAL SCHEME TO VIOLATE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS.
>> THE PAYMENTS WERE DESIGNED TO
BE PAID OVER THE COURSE OF 12
MONTHS.
AND IT WAS DECLARED TO BE A
RETAINER FOR SERVICES.
>> THE PRESIDENT DIRECTED
TRANSACTIONS IN CONSPIRACY WITH
ALAN WEISBERG AND HIS SON AS
PART OF A CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY OF
FINANCIAL FRAUD.
IS THAT YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
>> YES.
>> Bret: THEN, MARIE, BROUGHT
FORWARD TO GO DIFFERENT, BOTH
SIGNED BY THE PRESIDENT AND HE
SAID THAT THESE WERE PART OF
THAT PAYMENT.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> HE ALSO TESTIFIED THAT THE
REASON THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO
PAY OFF STORMY DANIELS WAS
EXPLICITLY TO IMPACT THE OUTCOME
OF THE ELECTION.
EVEN IF HE DIDN'T EXPECT TO WIN,
HE WAS TRYING TO IMPACT THAT.
I THINK ONE OF THE BIGGER, MORE
IMPORTANT THINGS WE HEARD TODAY
FROM MICHAEL COHEN WAS HIS
TESTIMONY THAT HE WITNESSED
OTHER CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR BY THE
PRESIDENT THAT THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK IS
CURRENTLY LOOKING INTO AND
THEREFORE COULDN'T GET INTO
THOSE DETAILS.
BUT HE OPENED THE DOOR TO THE
FACT THAT THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT
OF NEW YORK, THE PLACE THAT
HOLDS MORE LEGAL JEOPARDY FOR
THE PRESIDENT, THEY ARE LOOKING
INTO OTHER POSSIBLE CRIMINAL
ACTS.
I ALSO THINK ON THE RUSSIA
ISSUE, BRET, WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT
ROGER STONE AND WIKILEAKS, ROGER
STONE GIVING THE PRESIDENT HEADS
UP, THAT DOESN'T ANSWER
QUESTIONS BUT I THINK IT
ACTUALLY OPENS THE DOOR TO EVEN
MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT ELSE
DONALD TRUMP DISCUSSED WITH
ROGER STONE ABOUT WIKILEAKS.
WE DON'T KNOW.
>> Bret: I THINK ROGER STONE
TWEETED SOMETHING OUT A WEEK
BEFORE.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLIE, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> THE WHOLE THING WAS
INCREDIBLY ENTERTAINING.
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT LIKE
EPISODES OF "THE GODFATHER" ON A
NICE COLD RAINY DAY AND HE COULD
SIT INSIDE AND BE ENTERTAINED.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, THIS IS A
GUY WHO SAID DONALD TRUMP IS A
RACIST, IS A CON MAN, HE HATES
AMERICA, AND YET HE WORKED FOR
HIM FOR TEN YEARS?
OBVIOUSLY, HIS WHOLE RECORD FOR
VERACITY AROUND HERE IS NOT ALL
THAT GREAT.
MY FAVORITE MISS TRUTH OF THE
DAY WAS WHEN HE CLAIMED THAT THE
REASON THAT HE DECIDED TO FLIP
IS BECAUSE OF, YOU KNOW, A
CALLING OF HIS CONSCIOUS AND HE
WANTED TO CLEAR EVERYTHING UP.
NO, THE REASON HE FLIPPED IS
BECAUSE HIS OFFICE GOT RAIDED
AND THE REASON HE'S GOING TO
DALE COUNTY JAIL IS NOT BECAUSE
OF THE SUPPOSE CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATIONS TO IT WHICH, BY THE
WAY, THE LAST PERSON I WOULD GET
LEGAL ADVICE FROM ESPECIALLY ON
FEDERAL CAMPAIGN FINANCE IS
MICHAEL COHEN.
NOT WHO I'M GOING TO GO TO FOR
THAT.
>> Bret: HE ALSO -- GO AHEAD.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT OF COURSE, WHAT HE'S GOING
TO JAIL FOR IS DEFRAUDING ON HIS
TAXES AND DEFRAUDING HIS TAXING
MEDALLION BUSINESS.
>> Bret: HE ALSO SAID HE
DIDN'T WANT A WHITE HOUSE JOB.
THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE, EVEN
PUT IN THE FILING THAT HE WANTED
TO BE AT THE WHITE HOUSE BUT
HERE IS JIM JORDAN FROM OUR
INTERVIEW EARLY ON HIS TAKE ON
THE WHOLE THING.
>> LAST WEEK, TOM STEYER, MAKE A
DINNER FOR THE DEMOCRATS WAS IN
JERRY NADLER'S DISTRICT
ORGANIZING A TOWN HALL MEETING
TO PERSUADE MR. NADLER TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE AHEAD WITH
IMPEACHMENT.
TWO NIGHTS AGO, TOM STEYER WAS
IN BALTIMORE IN CHAIRMAN
CUMMINGS' DISTRICT, ENCOURAGING
HIS CONSTITUENTS TO PUSH AHEAD
WITH IMPEACHMENT THERE THAT'S
WHAT THIS THING WAS ABOUT TODAY.
>> Bret: MARC, THESE ARE
FRUSTRATING TO WATCH THE
QUESTIONING, OBVIOUSLY
REPUBLICANS DECIDED THAT THEY
WILL SPEND THEIR TIME TO REDUCE
OR TAKE AWAY ANY CREDIBILITY
THAT COHEN HAD.
BUT YOUR THOUGHTS ON THEIR
STRATEGY?
>> TAKING AWAY COHEN'S CREDIT
ABILITY IS LOW-HANGING FRUIT.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU, THEY HAVE A
POINT NOT ONLY ON COHEN'S
CREDIBILITY BUT THE DEMOCRATS'
CREDIBILITY.
TO HAVE THIS HEARING ON THIS
DAY, WHEN YOU'RE IN VIETNAM, THE
PRESIDENT IS IN VIETNAM MEETING
WITH KIM JONG UN, TRYING TO
FOCUS ON THE D&E REALIZATION OF
THE KOREAN PENINSULA WHICH IS
POSSIBLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE FACING
OUR COUNTRY AND BOTH SIDES,
EVERYBODY, HAS AN INTEREST IN
HIM SUCCEEDING, TO HAVE
SPECIFICALLY CHOSEN THIS DAY IN
ORDER TO HAVE -- THEY WANTED TO
HAVE A SPLIT SCREEN, IT'S